The answers are, from left to right, parallel, neither, perpendicular, and
perpendicular. We can see right off the bat that for the first pair of lines,
they have the same slope, 3. In the second pair of lines, it might at first look
you have similar situation, but because of this coefficient of 7 in front of our
y term in the 2nd equation, we actually end up seeing that we have a slope of 3
over 7 when we divide both sides by 7. So these lines are not parallel, nor are
they perpendicular. For the third pair, negative 3 times 1/3 is negative 1. Or
equivalently, 1/3 is equal to negative 1 over negative 3. Either way you look at
it, these lines are perpendicular. And last but not least, to figure out the
slope of this top of this equation, you need to divide both sides by two, which
gives us a slope of 1/2. In the second equation you see a coefficient in from of
the x term, of negative 2, and negative 1 over negative 2 is equal to 1/2. So
these two lines are perpendicular.